The joe rogan experience
cause they about that.
Ooh,
baby is coming
just dash.
Ooh.
So a g gone and
Nah,
to see
search the library.
But you all find anything.
If you don't fine p o baby,
eh,
it's
changing,
ma'am.
Maybe a Mama.
Hi.
Maybe Justin Sleeve.
Nah.
Yeah.
No,
I don't give a damn lie.
Oh baby.
Oh wait.
Changing Maggie.
Maggie.
So cool.
From Louisiana.
Ooh,
baby.
No.
The dark and how it can harm you.
Yeah.
Fun Too.
See,
awesome.
Yeah.
Wow.
Okay.
Oh God damn.
Suzanne bad mother.
I'm like,
God,
that's so good.
Thanks so much for having me.
It was really fun.
Woo.
That was all,
you just have a bottle of booze.
We got some good dogs.
Good.
That song is [inaudible].
You got to release that version too.
Oh,
thank God.
Oh God.
Oh,
that was awesome.